hello and welcome to deep dive the
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophies strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning this week i sat down with
web designer content creator and
entrepreneur olia known for his polished
minimalist aesthetic online and premium
tech blog ultralinks olya has built a
following of over a hundred thousand to
which he shares his tips on tech
lifestyle and financial independence in
our conversation we talk about
everything from dropping out of school
and making six hundred thousand dollars
from selling tumblr themes i'm in a very
fortunate position where i get to do
stuff that i enjoy already for work
i just happen to also make money with it
to the art of dropshipping and the
lessons he learned from beating cancer
all right olio welcome to the podcast
how are you doing i'm doing okay
we still don't have a name for the
podcast we were brainstorming podcast
names earlier this morning i liked
unplugged unplugged okay
but but but it's not my podcast i mean
unplugged could work afternoon tea deep
dive i'm sure afternoon
i'm sure by the time this goes out we
actually will have a name for the
podcast and so
when i do my intro about you i'll say
hey friends welcome back to the podcast
and people won't know that this is uh
um
anyway first thing i wanted to ask you
how the hell have you made over 600
thousand dollars from selling tumblr
themes like what's going on there what
was the story okay so this is a good
story so
i've done a video on it before but i'll
just go through i can't remember exactly
what i said but
um obviously i i was into i was into
tumblr i was anti-using tumblr i had my
tumblr blog and was to post images and
stuff it was literally like having a
mood board that's what that's how i use
tumblr i used it as a mood board
i liked posting images on there and i
thought hey i want to modify my tumblr
website i want i want to i want to make
it look more like what i wanted to look
like you know i want it to be more me
so i started messing around with the
code and stuff messing around with the
design and stuff i thought hey you know
let's let's see what i can do
and i sort of just fell into
messing around and making tumblr themes
it was literally by chance and then i
could see you know hey tumblr had a ton
of theme garden they were selling themes
on there i had no idea how much people
were making on there to be honest
i thought it was maybe like a thousand
dollars two thousand dollars a month um
so then i started just making themes
going into it not really having high
expectations
went into it and then here i was one or
two months where i made like 30 000 a
month and i was i was just like what i
was like 21 at the time so you can
imagine 21 year old having that sort of
money it's just like holy crap like what
am i going to do now i feel like
that was actually a very big turning
point in my life because before that i
was earning quite little money um but
the timeless themes definitely
transformed my life tumblr probably
don't know that
i don't know that i actually literally
changed my life in terms of what i could
do and the possibilities that came along
from that so you had a tumblr blog and
you decided you wanted to modify your
own page to make it look more like you
and then you thought let's sell sell how
much how much were you selling these
themes for so tumblr has three different
pricing models well three percent
pricing tiers nine dollars nineteen
dollars and forty nine dollars i was
trying to make themes on the higher end
forty nine dollars there were some more
simpler themes that were not nineteen
dollars but most of them were forty nine
dollars each okay and so you make the
theme once and then you can sell it
multiple times 49 whoever wants to use
that theme to make that tumblr page look
like yours can use it exactly yeah
exactly how how did you know how to make
tumblr themes like yeah
well tumblr luckily have a very easy
documentation that you can follow and
it's nowhere near as complicated as some
of the other sort of platforms out there
like wordpress you could say tumblr is
very very simple i think anyone who
learns html css can learn to make a
tumblr theme it is very very simple fair
play so how old were you when you
stumbled onto this gold mine of tumblr
themes
well um
i knew of tumblr since i was like 18 19.
but making actual tumblr things and
making money i was around like 20 21 oh
if i play okay so i wonder if we can
rewind back to sort of early life so
let's say you know what were you like in
in secondary school sort of age age 11
to 18 how did you spend your time were
you like a massive nerd back then as
well like what was the vibe
i feel like i was one of those kids that
sort of sat in the background at school
and i i would i wouldn't say i was a
nerd but i also wouldn't say i was like
oh really popular kid you know i was
just passively going through school
mainly because i didn't enjoy school um
but yeah like my school life i i didn't
really enjoy school that much if i'm
always i'm not a very academic person
okay
and then you didn't go to university no
so what did what did you do instead so i
went to college
because i didn't even do a-levels i went
to college and i did like a level three
course level four courses like that um
on accounting and business because i
thought i was going to become an
accountant
i'm really glad that didn't happen but
whilst i was doing that that's when i
started getting into
computers and stuff that's when i
started getting into websites and stuff
like that because i started my blog the
ultralinks.com that i don't really post
on it anymore it's kind of dead now but
i started posting on that 2010 2010
and what sparked that
was an android phone that i bought at
the time i bought an android phone i
wanted to customize it you know changing
your icons and wallpapers was like a
really big thing it's quite a nerdy
thing to do
and i would share it on the blog
and i guess that's where i started when
it comes to
building any sort of online presence
were you would have been around 17-ish
at the time
um yeah yeah well they're about 17-18
yeah okay
so
it's a it's a pretty random thought
process to have at the age of 17. you
know what i want to customize my android
phone therefore i'm going to start a
blog like what was the
what was the link there so
the first place that i actually started
finding people customizing their phones
was a forum it was just a forum online
and people were posting their their
screens on the forum they're posting
their customizations on the forum and i
just thought to myself hey you know why
i can post another forum but i can also
post it on a blog my own sort of little
corner of the internet you could say
um so i'd post it there and then i'd get
people to come to my blog as well and
that's how i sort of built it and that's
what sort of sparked me to make the blog
okay and this was a tumblr blog no this
was actually just a normal like like
wordpress so it wasn't even wordpress it
was google blogspot oh well it's like a
really old school
but i moved it over to wordpress
i think in 2012.
okay so two years later yeah so what
sort of stuff were you posting on the
blog for that two year period two year
period i was just posting i was posting
anything i found interesting okay i was
obviously interested in like design and
stuff and product design all these
different things i post like i'd even
post like apple news or like new phone
news smartphone news all these different
things
literally whatever i found interesting
there wasn't any rigid structure
um but it was just whatever i liked and
what sort of traffic were you getting to
the blog between in that time period so
i think 2012 2013
2013 i was getting around half a million
views a month bloody hell so that's a
lot
but you say that at the time um i wasn't
really making much money from it okay
because i didn't really know how to
monetize it and cpms weren't that high
back then either um so yeah i wasn't
really making much money from my blog
until around 2013. okay hang on so see
so you started the blog in 2010 posting
about these android things or posting
random stuff that you were interested in
how did it get so popular so to have 500
000 views a month i honestly don't know
yeah
okay i honestly don't know i think it is
just a matter of
people like seeing the customizations i
guess it goes down to another reason why
i guess people like follow me on
instagram or youtube
they like my sort of this sounds so
pompous but they like myself style and
aesthetic you could say you've even said
it before like i had this like sort of
certain aesthetic
and i think that's why people liked it
okay that's what people like to tell me
anyway and how did you develop this
aesthetic over time oh yeah i honestly
don't know either i think it is just one
of those things where i was like hey i
like this hair like that um
i think
i i didn't really have anyone where
they sort of sparked my interest in that
aesthetic yep
i think it was just a matter of hey you
know i grew up in a house where
everything was really messy yep and now
i want everything to be like really sort
of clean and minimal got it
so i think that's what maybe sparkle
just wanted the opposite
so
let's say we're in 2010 you've posted
your first blog post presumably no one
is reading the blog at this point
because it's your first blog post
and then presumably you had to post
fairly consistently to build kind of the
the authority and the
the blog over time
how did you
bring yourself to continue to post on it
in the early days when you weren't
getting that feedback of views and
comments and stuff yeah of course i
think obviously when you're like 17 18
19 20 that sort of age range i feel like
you kind of just
a lot of the things you do you do it
because you enjoy it right you you don't
go into it making money
um
into it like make thinking that you're
gonna make a lot of money and that is
literally i just enjoyed sharing that
stuff online i enjoyed sharing like like
you do like you know you make these
videos everyone makes these videos
youtubers make their videos because they
want to share
their opinions um whatever they're
making whatever they're doing same sort
of thing for me and i wanted to do it on
a blog
so now we're in 2013 your blog is
getting half a million hits a month like
what do you what does it what does a day
in your life look like
so at the time obviously i was at
college i was studying and stuff um
learning at college and i'd only go to
college i think three or four times a
week so the rest of the time i had a lot
of free time and it's why i would post
on the blog it's why i would do that
sort of stuff um
again my schedule was very open um like
it is now i don't i don't like to have a
rigid structure um but i did obviously
nearly every day post stuff on on the
blog
because i enjoyed doing it you know if i
had a few hours here and there i would
just do it because i enjoyed doing it
okay so at what point did it turn from
something you enjoy doing into more of
like a business
if if ever 2013 i think um
when i left college i thought to myself
okay i can either go to university or i
can carry on with this blog thing um
like i said i wasn't really making any
money i wasn't making much money and i
thought to myself let's give myself 12
months
if i can make say two grand a month for
example then i'm rolling like two grand
a month that's 24 000 pounds for a year
for me and i'm 21. that's great for
money for me at the time
and yeah like 2013 the blog was making
that sort of money and then i remember
there were some months where it was
making like five grand a month five
thousand dollars a month um how how was
it making money in the early days
through banner ads like google adsense
stuff yeah you're making up to 5k a
month from
google adsense on the blog yeah and
sponsored posts as well so sometimes
like you know a brand would be like hey
can we post our product can we post a
link or whatever um
and i would charge for that damn okay
so you've got this blog that was then
going what was your next sort of hustle
that you added to the to the mix it was
my themes
so
um
the themes theme really took over
because obviously the themes making 20
30 000 a month um
that's much more of a lucrative thing to
do than the blog so
that's where i focus a lot of my time
and that's why i focus my time for
around two years three years okay um
it's like making more and more themes or
yeah making more themes and supporting
the themes because obviously there'll be
a lot of people who buy one and they
need to customize it or they need to
change something and i had quite a few i
say famous people like
justin bieber for example was used
but i'm sure it wasn't justin bieber
himself i'm sure it was his team for
example um
i had brands like bmw
and some other random brands as well
something like big companies use my my
tumblr themes
which is actually really great to see
like it sort of gave me that sort of
seal of approval you could say showing
that hey if these brands are using it
then surely i'm doing something right
yeah i remember around around that time
like 2013 to 2015 i
i was
getting i i was using wordpress quite a
lot for my business that i'd set up at
the time sure and on places like
themeforest i was seeing just how much
money people were making through
wordpress themes and i tried to dabble
with wordpress theme development myself
one summer and i just it went down the
rabbit hole and it was just so hard that
i thought you know what i see why
these guys are making the big bucks from
from selling these teams for fifty
dollars
um so you're working on this on this for
two years what did that what did that
feel like that first month where you
suddenly make thirty thousand dollars
that's just completely insane for like a
21 year old
21 making that sort of money in fact
even even like now
you know yeah that's like a doctor's
salary for a whole year that you've made
in a month off of selling website themes
no you're completely right making that
sort of money even now is just insane
um
but yeah at 21 i just thought to myself
i luckily didn't go off the rails i
didn't i didn't go crazy anything hey
i'm making all this money let's spend
this right away
i saved a lot of it i saved a lot of it
because i realized like
just growing up with that money anyway
like my parents you know they didn't
have
they didn't have a lot of money didn't
have like any high paying jobs or
whatever um and i knew that you know
making this sort of money this is some
of the most money
ever like even my parents have ever seen
so i knew that i couldn't waste it i
knew that i had to put it away
and do something with it so i knew from
quite early on maybe since i was like 19
20
that was important to save up for like a
deposit for a house for example i knew
that was important that's what i did i
saved a lot of it just so that i could
buy my own place and not be dependent on
my parents
i really like this point that you made
about how
in the in the early days you're not
you're not really doing it for the money
you're doing it because you enjoy it
um i wanted to ask did you enjoy like
100 of it or like 80 of it like what
were the because because everything has
bits that are like less fun like how do
you how did you think about those back
in the day yeah sure so the way i see it
is sometimes you've got to go through a
little bit of struggle here and there to
have like that delayed gratification you
could say
where you know going through a struggle
for a label or just doing something you
don't like means that
it can you can do something that you do
like almost in a way it's like it's like
a vice versa sort of exchange almost in
a way that's how i see it
um i still i still sort of stand by that
i saw sort of things myself hey you know
if i work hard now if i do this now if i
just get it done now i don't have to
think about it later even for example
you know
i don't know you probably don't know
what this is like but i hate having my
kitchen dirty for example i ain't having
the dishes out of stuff i just think to
myself it only takes me five minutes to
put my dishes away i just do it now
because once it's done i don't have to
think about it later on okay it's that
sort of thing for me okay so what was
the what were the areas of struggle that
that were the equivalent to the putting
the dishes away sure in this sort of
business so when when i was doing the
tumblr themes for example the hardest
part was doing the more complex coding
so i wasn't very good with javascript
for example
so
something like that i really didn't
enjoy it i didn't want to learn it so
with the themes that i had made the
simpler themes i used the money that i
made from those teams to hire an
external developer to make and do the
more complex stuff for me
and
you can hire someone to do that quite
cheaply if you
find someone online you know doesn't
have to be someone in the uk it can be
it can be something you go somewhere in
the us but finding a javascript
developer just to make a few changes
here in there to add some things to a
theme that you've already made is quite
affordable okay no fair play and and
just on this note of like having having
fun with stuff do you think for you
you
do you think you for you it was more
that you found something that you happen
to find fun
or alternatively that you found ways to
make this thing fun for yourself like
what yeah i think i found something that
was just fun like i i wasn't looking for
it i just
i literally just stumbled across it like
i was into customizing my phone at the
time anyway like you know when i when we
talk about the blog starting the blog
and stuff
i just enjoy customizing my phone the
side benefit was hey i can share this
with other people and then obviously you
just sort of spiraled into doing all
these different things and now here i am
doing this with you i guess
which is just so hilarious when you when
i think back like all these little
things have led me here yeah and do you
think would it be fair to say that you
were like
kind of just chasing the things that you
found fun at eat junction and it
happened to lead you here or was there
more of a sort of strategic
vision behind any of this stuff there is
some strategic sort of strategic sort of
vision
um
but
i i don't think it's it's like very
i don't like i said i don't really have
a proper structure um
i sort of just think to myself hey okay
what is it i enjoy doing now like as an
adult now as a
28 year old i think to myself what is it
i enjoy doing now
and you know
can i can i make money from it
is it something i can i can see myself
doing in say two years five years ten
years or whatever um
that's how i see things now but i wasn't
like that when i was like 20 years old
21 years old i kind of just thought hey
let's just see what happens let's see
how things go because
you just don't know you don't have the
life experience right so you just don't
know okay
so so
sounds like 2010 to 2013 it was like
your blog days
and then 2013 through 2015 was your
tumblr theme heyday yeah yeah so
now it's it's 2015. what what what's
what's all you're doing in 2015. yeah so
2015 was a big year
not in terms of money in terms of um
what i was going to do next so 2015 was
actually when i got my first office and
made my first hire
so 2015 june 2015 i've got my own office
space
and that's actually where i started
making youtube videos as well my first
youtube video is a tour of my office
space okay that i made with my iphone
you don't even see my face on it yep
this is just me going around showing my
office space why did you get an office
space
um just because i was still at home
living at home with my parents okay um
working from a room which was like three
by three it was absolutely tiny i
couldn't even fit a wardrobe in it i had
like a bed and a desk okay so you're
making 30k a month and you're thinking
you know what let's
let's like upgrade
the live setup yeah okay so i ended up
getting an office for quite cheap it was
only like
9 000 pounds a year so very very cheap
without an office space um but it was
like the size of my parents house
so i just thought hey this is good yeah
it's investing and it means i don't have
my parents always sort of like coming in
and being like hey ollie you can't do
this can you do that yeah you know i
don't have people walking in randomly
you know whatever say i have a proper
office space where i can actually work
from and where
i can have employees yeah whatever so
who was your first hire so charlie um
was my first i went to college with him
we kept in touch like because i left
college like 2012. we kept in touch over
the years
and yeah i was just like hey charlie do
you wanna come work for me and i was
like yeah let's do it and he's been
working for me since what was charlie
doing for you in the early days so in
the early days charlie was actually
posting on the blog he was he took over
the blog pretty much he was
managing that that website
and then his role in the business in the
company changed it keeps changing to be
honest he doesn't have a specific role i
like to call him operations manager oh
because it makes him you know it sounds
important yeah i mean that's similar to
angus title which is operations director
so
you know i'm just like hey charlie i
need this thing only that dude can you
do it whatever yeah charlie's very
flexible person it's nice having a
person like that and i'm sure you know
because you have angus be that person
for you yeah just sort of doing anything
and everything if like anything comes up
and you don't have the time or maybe you
just you literally just can't do it you
need someone else to do it yep
nice so it's 2015 you've got your office
space what prompted you to turn it into
a youtube video because that was also a
bit of a weird thing to do in 2015 that
it it's not a thought process a lot of
people would have had that hey let me
let me film a youtube video of my office
true yeah
so when i got my office space
i was like any person start looking for
inspiration yep for office space setups
and stuff like that right of course both
of our channels are like our office
workspace setups are some of the most
popular videos
right so
i saw all these little setups on on
youtube and stuff and i thought to
myself
hey i can just share my one because i
was also posting on instagram at the
time and i will share a picture of my
workspace on instagram
and i used to get a lot of comments
of people asking me hey can you post a
video on it on youtube have you ever
seen it okay
um
and that's where i sort of fell into
just doing youtube we're going to take a
very quick break to introduce our
sponsor for this episode and that is
brilliant i've been using brilliant for
the last two plus years they're a
fantastic platform for learning maths
science and computer science with
engaging and interactive online courses
and the great thing about brilliant is
that they really teach stuff from a very
first principles based approach it's
almost like the way that we were taught
in places like oxford and cambridge
where you learn a concept and then you
apply the concept to an interesting
problem rather than just being spoon-fed
stuff like we initially learned in
school my favorite courses on brilliant
are the computer science ones as some of
you guys might know i was torn between
applying to medicine and computer
science i went for medicine in the end
but i always had an affinity to computer
science and taking the courses on
brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science and head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off for the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode
okay so your first video was the office
tour
at what point did you decide hey i'm i'm
going to become a youtuber and start
actually making youtube videos well it's
funny because i still don't see myself
as a youtuber okay because i don't do
youtube full-time i still do youtube
probably two or two days a week okay oh
you're a part-time youtuber yeah i'm a
part-time youtuber um i don't know when
i decided hey you know i can just start
doing youtube videos i think it is just
because
i know the thing that you like to always
say is you need to be consistent if you
want to build a youtube channel you need
to consistently post yeah but for me it
wasn't like that
for me i was posting whenever i just
wanted a post i didn't have a schedule
okay i maybe post two videos a week some
and then i might not place like a month
because i was still running other parts
of my business but as youtube started
growing and as as the income started
growing from youtube i realized hey i'm
on to something here
and i started dedicating more time to it
and that's why now i dedicate two days a
week to it but
i don't ever see youtube becoming a
full-time thing for me
ideally i don't actually want it to be
okay mainly because i like doing other
stuff i like starting other businesses i
like running other businesses um
i i just can't see myself doing youtube
full-time
okay how how did you get your first
let's say one one thousand to ten
thousand subscribers
through instagram
okay so
on instagram
if we go back a bit on instagram i was
posting pictures of setups and products
and things like that um
and i was going very quickly on
instagram
instagram algorithm at the time was very
favorable to me i was gaining around 10
000 followers a month at one point well
which is just crazy i don't think i've
ever had a month on youtube where i've
got 10 000 subscribers um
but yeah from there
it just
i i started directing people yeah being
like hey come to my youtube channel
i've uploaded a video there and i
realized from doing that
that
i enjoyed making videos i enjoyed doing
all the stuff that goes into videos and
also i realized that hey i can make
quite a bit more money on youtube
compared to instagram
and i'll also realize that instagram was
sort of they change the algorithm they
change the way things like instagram is
not the same as it was 2015 2015 all you
could do on instagram was post photos i
think you couldn't post videos you
couldn't post
and i think you could even post portrait
photos i think it was still square
and yeah so so i focus a lot more on
youtube now compared to any of my other
social channels yeah so if we it's it
sounds like the the trajectory of things
from like 2010 to 2015-ish was
you
you find this thing that you enjoy i.e
product design and this sort of
aesthetic you post about it alongside
like phone customizations and stuff on
the blog you start posting on the blog
consistently the tumblr theme thing sort
of is a bit of a side gig that's not
fully related to that but i suppose your
aesthetic kind of comes into that as
well i think one thing we didn't talk
about was
in that time i'd say between 2013 and
2017
20 yeah 20
i i was doing a lot of client work as
well kind of work so what we're doing
for clients for example designing
websites designing apps things like that
okay um
and that also came about because i was
obviously customizing my android phone
yeah to customize your android phone yep
you have to go into photoshop and you
have to mess around with graphics and ui
elements and stuff like that
and again it's just nothing i enjoy
doing
and over time i agree i've got the
confidence of like maybe i can charge
money for this maybe i can maybe i can
you know
post my my designs online and see if
anyone hires me
and i used to post on the website called
dribble.com oh yeah so dribble was very
popular from like 2012 to 2015 2016 at
the time um and i got a lot of a lot of
clients through dribble okay so
and they were all very i say all most of
them were quite high paying clients so
at the time of things going i had the
blog going and i was doing design work
so i had a good sort of three
four income streams there
doing all sorts of stuff and i enjoyed
doing all of it yeah
i just enjoyed doing all of it i wasn't
always busy because i didn't have client
work all the time but the client work it
was great like i enjoyed doing stuff for
other for other companies and just
having that experience okay and it
sounded like it all sort of stemmed from
this decision in 2010 to post on a blog
yeah um because one thing i often say to
people is that like starting a blog can
literally change your life and that
seems like that's been the case for you
probably one of the best cases of that
right
nice okay so
getting back to the story so we're 2015
at this point you've got your blog
you've got your tumblr themes that are
selling you've got your client workers
on the side you've got your instagram
and you've just started youtube yeah
what does kind of olia's empire look
like for the next few years
so
from 2015 to 2019 i was going to the
office every day okay um
is it 2019. yeah i was pretty much going
to office every day um but in 2017 i
bought my own house i purchased my house
and ever since i bought my own house i
was sort of splitting the time between
the office and home
mainly because
this is going to sound so ridiculous but
it was half an hour commute and i just
thought hey i could do a lot of my work
at home yep and then let's go to the
office because at home
it's just me there's no one to disturb
me i don't have any sort of distractions
from family or anything so
yes it's sort of
those sort of years i was doing the same
sort of stuff i was doing
themes i was doing design work i was
doing
youtube and instagram and stuff
but i also started a shopify store i
started ulex.com
eulexstore.com
in 2017 2016 2017 okay i was
experimenting with shopify at the time i
actually started a few shopify stores
yep um
because drop shipping was a big thing at
the time okay and i started doing drop
shipping just to see what it's like and
i realized drop shipping
at the time it was a bit of a
i feel like i got a bad rep okay so for
people who might be listening who don't
know what shopify or drop shipping are
or what how would you describe those so
shopify
is just the platform so use shopify to
sell products online physical products
online and then drop shipping
is when
you have products on your store
but then
you
don't actually have the products in
stock with you you have someone else
send their products maybe a factory in
china or a factory in the uk or a
manufacturer or it could just be old jim
who lives down the road and makes makes
leather wallets in his little shed or
whatever you know he you would just send
an order to to that person to the drop
shipper and they would send the order
directly to the customer so there's no
you don't have to get involved with the
actual product management and shipping
the product you're sort of just making
the sale getting the customer okay so
customer buys from your site but what
the customer probably doesn't realize is
that behind the scenes jim has got his
collection of leather goods and jim is
the one sending him the thing yes but
it's as if you're the one sending him
the thing okay
how does how does that work like why
does that work so
it's funny because i feel like drop
shipping gets a bad rep because of long
shipping times and things like that but
what i think a lot of people don't
realize is that every single major
company in the world apart from amazon
does drop shipping even apple does drop
shipping wait
how so because apple obviously
have a fulfillment center in ireland for
example um for the uk and that's where
all the products are shipped from and
that fulfillment center might not
actually be run by apple it might be run
by completely third party yeah when i
get apple products they're from like
synctron or some some company like that
i'm like what the hell is exactly yeah
it's just it's just a third party
handling all the logistics and the and
the shipping and everything for apple
and that's a very common thing okay
which people don't seem to realize drop
shipping isn't a new thing it's been
around for decades it's been around for
a long time because i guess when you
hear drop shipping you think scam yeah
exactly
yeah which is such a shame it's like
it's like the word entrepreneur now yeah
it's a little bit cringe yeah
same with drop shipping i think that's
exactly what's happening okay so you
were one of the og well i guess
2017 wasn't really og but like you you
were doubling it dabbling and drop
shipping and i was making maybe
a couple of thousand dollars a month but
it wasn't very profitable and it wasn't
a good business okay
so how are you making a couple of
thousand dollars a month from drop
shipping like what what does that look
like so a couple thousand dollars a
month because that seems pretty good
yeah it looks pretty good um but it
wasn't very profitable oh and then
revenue-wise as opposed to profit wise
yeah so what sort of stuff were you
selling so it would have been like
macbook sleeves and and felt desk mats
and things like that okay um you know i
had i i'd
buy them from china or whatever but i
realized that
doing drop shipping like that the
shipping times are just way too long for
customers so
i took it a step further and i thought
to myself hey why don't i have the space
i have this this office space i can
store the products here so i would bulk
buy products like any normal retailer
like any normal business i'd buy the
products i store them in my office space
and we would send them out from here we
would send them to customers in the uk
in the eu and the us because it's much
quicker than having a supplier in china
do it for us okay so you would buy like
a thousand units in bulk of like a
macbook sleeve from china exactly store
them in your house office yeah and
physically like ship them to people
around the world because you have a lot
more control over the customer service
yeah and the sort of the way the
business works
um it's also quite a bit more profitable
because obviously you're buying products
in bulk rather than buying each time a
customer buys okay
so you're selling this stuff on a
shopify store and how did how did things
grow from that kind of 2017 onwards so i
realized that hey you know i'm making
money and i
if we go back to your question about how
was i making money i was marketing it
mainly through my instagram profile yep
i'd post the products on my instagram
profile and i'd have followers and stuff
who were interested by it you know
that's how it started with drop shipping
and stuff i realized hey you know if i
want to make more money if i want to do
this properly
i need to start designing my own
products
so i started designing my own products
in photoshop in sketch just literally
writing down on paper if i have to
and i would come up with other products
that i like the look of put it all
together in like a pdf document send it
off to a manufacturer in china
and i'd be like hey can you make this
can you make this for me with my logo on
it yeah um it's funny because it sounds
very like half
ass in a way but it's a very common
thing that most people do but um so you
can just do that you can just design
something on a napkin and send it to
someone in china and they will be like
yes
our factory can make this for you
exactly that's pretty cool yeah exactly
it's
i think the toughest part of it is you
do need capital obviously because to buy
a thousand units um to buy sample
products it does cost a lot of money
like a sample can cost
anybody seen a hundred to like a
thousand dollars for example because
they're only making one unit and
sometimes they have to
adjust the tooling adjust the
manufacturing all that sort of stuff to
just make a sample yeah but then once
you've made at some point you're happy
with it you make a bug order sometimes
they actually take off the sample fee
which is pretty nice
can anyone just do this like is there a
website that you go on where you can
just like find a factory in china to
make a thing for you like how does it
work there's a website i feel like most
people know of who are in that sort of
world called alibaba.com where you can
go to and you can
find manufacturers and stuff and you can
work with them and making your own
custom products so do you like ring them
up or have a zoom
how does that actually work like if i
let's say i wanted to design the perfect
backpack for my everyday carry sure
which is the thing i want to do at some
point you know perfectly sized for a
13-inch macbook 11-inch ipad
that would be that would be really cool
so what would that process look like i
don't like i i have a vision for like
the perfect backpack so
like i said the first thing you need to
do is come up with a sketch come up with
any features that you like come up with
anything that you'd want in the backpack
any sort of
key requirements that you want
look at other backpacks you like the
look of um take the best bits of them
and then mix and mash them together
almost
send that off to a manufacturer you go
on alibaba you can put in an rfq which
is request for quite okay and
you upload your design file or designs
or whatever you tell them the
measurements the materials that you like
and then you usually have like a bunch
of supplies get back in touch with you
and then from there
you do have to spend quite a bit of time
researching each supplier seeing what
other products they've made in the past
seeing if they have any products that
are similar to what you've already made
because obviously if they have made
similar products it's going to be much
easier working with them in making the
product that you want okay and what does
like working with them look like like on
a day-to-day basis do you like go to
china and talk to them how how does it
how does that how does that like i
literally know nothing about what it's
like to so i'm a complete noob about
this so i've never been to china in my
life okay it's all done online and it's
all done on alibaba.com you can even
have the orders done through there okay
alibaba provide like protection yeah so
say you ordered ten thousand dollars
worth of stock and it doesn't meet the
spec that you sent to them say there's
something off you can get you can
sometimes get your money back really
depends it can it can depend um and yeah
it's all just done through alibaba just
through dms
pretty much yeah you can send them if
you have slack or whatsapp you can send
them your contact details and you can
talk to them through there as if like
they were a friend but obviously
the biggest issue with that is that
there is a language barrier of course
they do speak the chinese most of them
and they sometimes have a rep who can
speak english but even then it's quite
it's quite broken english sometimes
you'll get some people who are great you
can speak english very well but some
people are quite broken english and
again it's just something you have to
work through and figure out okay
so how long does it take from like kind
of idea for designing a product to
getting a sample in your hand from a
factory in china for you good question
good question so
designing a product coming up with the
designer stuff can maybe take me a
couple of days because
usually these product designs just come
alongs randomly i'm like hey i want to
make this product
designing it whatever two or three days
sending it off on alibaba looking for a
manufacturer
that can take maybe a week or two
figuring out who to make a sample with
you who should make your sample and then
getting a sample may can sometimes take
up to 60 days it can take a long time
two months
and then once you're happy with the
sample because maybe you're not happy
with the first sample you might have to
get another one maybe so it means
another two months
but once you're happy with the sample
again it can be anywhere between 60
to 120 days until you actually get the
products
in in your hands okay and do you ever
have to worry about quality control for
the samples for the for the bulk order
yeah of course of course so
there are different ways you can do this
you can hire
a third party in china to check the
products for you or you can just have
the manufacturer send you pictures and
stuff see what the products are like um
there's always risk involved as anything
like this there's always risk um
but it's just one of the things of
making products online making physical
products what's been the biggest kind of
uh mistake slash downside like bad thing
that has happened to you as a result of
trying to sell physical stuff online
yeah i've actually shared this in a
video before i can't remember the exact
amount
that i lost but i think it was
i can't remember i can't remember if it
was ten
i know i've lost more than ten thousand
dollars i think it was maybe thirty
thousand dollars something like that
where i bought some stock and it wasn't
up to scratch
and
i just couldn't get a refund i went
through the bank i went through alibaba
and
i i couldn't sell these products like
they worked and everything but the logo
just wasn't right it just didn't look
good enough yep so
you'll just have to write it off yeah i
just had to write it off at least you
had to throw it in the bin which is a
shame because it's a waste of resources
it's a waste of money it's a waste of
materials like it's just
also not very good for a penny either so
um that's probably one of the biggest
things and
thankfully that's never happened since
because i've learned my lesson okay well
what what what else was that i think it
was just a matter of being a lot more
giving a lot more attention to the
samples giving a lot more attention to
the bulk order yeah making sure they
send me high resolution pictures of the
bulk order yup
of like maybe uh maybe i'll get them to
send me
pictures of like five or six items in
the blog order just to see what they
look like and making sure
that the spec i've written is as
detailed as it can possibly be
because then
i can go to alibaba and be like hey you
know look they haven't followed the spec
so they haven't made the product okay
to my requirements i want my money back
oh
and you can just like say to the factory
hey i want photos and they'll be like
all right here you go yes most most
factories most good factories anyway
would be happy to send you photos and
they'll even send you photos if you like
on the inside of the factory yep so you
can see working conditions and things
like that make sure you know
if things are things that's going up to
scratch and that there's no children
working in there for example because i
know i'll see that can be a big thing
yeah when working with manufacturers
and you just got to hope you know unless
you can visit the factory yourself
you just got to hope that there are
children working there and alibaba
usually does vet all the manufacturers
that they have on their website um to
make sure obviously that they meet the
the rules and the laws that are in place
okay
so how if you if you're open to sharing
how profitable is it to run a sort of
physical products business that you
where you design stuff manufacture in
china bring it back to the uk and ship
it from the uk
what does that look like it can really
really vary it can really really vary so
um you know it can be anything like
maybe five percent profit margins so
like 60 70 i've seen some businesses
that makes 60 70 profit margins because
maybe they already for example like you
already have an audience so they don't
only spend money online marketing for
example because marketing i think is the
biggest expense for any any business
which is selling products
physical products um so yeah it can vary
a lot
okay so if i wanted to make the sort of
work with you to design this like
perfect backpack yeah that would fit my
everyday carrier take the office every
day maybe in three different colors and
then
spin up a shopify store
pitch it to the audience
what do you think will
what would be your estimate of like
ballpark costs and how much we sell this
for like what would that look like if we
were constructing a business out of this
again it just varies so much it depends
on
backpack materials the spec of the
backpack pockets and whatever okay but
let's just say let's just say you wanted
quite a hike yeah i want something sort
of peak design style slash like you know
high-end i think it would cost you
anywhere between 20 to 50 per unit oh
okay so per unit yep and
then sell it for like 200 per unit
exactly i think that's a big surprise a
lot of people don't seem to have they
think oh you know iphones cost two
hundred dollars three hundred dollars to
make but then they sell them for a
thousand dollars i think a lot of people
don't realize that's just the material
cost yep there's so much cost involved
for example your time of making the
backpack logistics shipping because most
likely you're gonna offer free shipping
yeah shipping is expensive man very very
expensive i feel like we've all gone
used to free shipping yeah amazon but
amazon it cost them a lot of money yeah
they've got a lot of efficiency
efficient things in place that's why
they can do it yeah but yeah like it's
actually quite standard to see a 200 250
backpack that only costs 50 to make okay
that's quite a that's quite a standard
thing and so 50 for the cost of the
backpack what would be the ballpark
costs for the other stuff associated
with selling a backpack on the internet
i i don't know really with ballpark
cosplayers because like shipping how
much how much does shipping cost like
when you're selling when you're sending
your stuff out so for example shipping a
backpack for example to someone in the
u.s can cost us like
thirty dollars forty dollars bloody hill
okay exactly more than the actual
product itself yeah which is very common
okay very very common thing and then i
guess if you're running ads and things
then
it all adds up but the nice thing about
ads is you can really track the roi
return on investment of the ads yeah so
you would you would hope that you can
spend let's say
10 000 a month put it on your american
express get the points and
you will literally see a return of maybe
30 000 a month from those ads 30 000 is
on the high end okay so a good ballpark
is
is like around two so for every dollar
you spend you make two dollars but again
it very much depends on the product so
for example say you're selling an
electric scooter that's a thousand
dollars you know
the
roi on that could be around
one or two or three but because the
product is a lot more expensive spending
500 on an ad to make a thousand dollars
you made a 500 profit there or 500
margin which is obviously like say
10 20 iphone cases or even more like you
know 50 iphone cases so
yeah like it just varies so much from
product to product okay
so
you you started this thing in in 2017
what are what are things looking like
now with the physical products that
you're that you're selling what does the
store look like so in the last year um
you know with ulextor.com we generated a
million dollars over a million dollars
um which is obviously like for me that's
amazing like that's a crazy amount of
money to make in a business i've never
had a business which has made that much
money in 12 months um so yeah like it's
doing pretty well but
um again i don't focus my full time on
it
luckily i have three other people
working on that business so they manage
it for me i have
charlie obviously doing the operations
doing the shipments customer service
stuff like that i have um ivan who's
doing
product sourcing product management
because obviously talking to my talking
to manufacturers talking to people on
whatsapp takes up a lot of time and it's
something that i outsource to him he
works full time and then i have a guy
um in new zealand who's doing my
advertising for me marketing facebook
instagram advertising stuff like that
okay
that's pretty cool and so what is your
like right now in 2021 what does your
sort of your your empire look like
you've got you've got the store what
else what else do you have in your i've
got the youtube channel yep um
i've got
i guess digital products on my website
things like lightroom presets and um
wallpapers and icons and stuff
you know they don't make an absolute ton
of money well i say they don't make a
ton of money they still make quite good
money around
you know it can be well they can vary so
when i was doing the icons for example
remember when i ios 14 ideas really blew
up um you know i was making tens of
thousands a month um
so yeah it can vary so much but
icons and digital products
i sometimes take on client work
so consulting you know someone might
hire me for even just half an hour
and because they want feedback on a
product so they want feedback on their
business
um and i can hopefully provide some
value to them
um
and that's it right now i think yeah
okay what's next for you like how do you
how do you how do you think about what
you want to do next because you've got
like a pretty comfortable sort of suite
of products yeah you could sit back and
essentially live off this
for the foreseeable future sure how do
you think about what to do next
so i think at some point i would like to
sell your lxstore.com i'd like to sell
it um mainly because i think my interest
in doing freezer products has has sort
of shifted quite a bit
i realized that i want to do more i feel
like i want to start a software as a
service business i don't know what yeah
trying to dabble in some ideas um i
think that's my next step doing software
as a service and of course going to
youtube posting on youtube and stuff um
because i think it's always nice to have
an audience that you can speak to that
you can share things with yeah awesome
so we've talked a lot about kind of the
business side of life i wonder if we can
talk about some personal stuff
um
and so was it a year ago
that or
longer than that that you got first
first diagnosed with with cancer oh yeah
what was the story there it's august 3rd
now yeah so i was diagnosed july
7th last year 2020. yeah so sort of peak
peak lock down yeah
and yeah so
it's funny because i had i i think i've
spoken to to you about this before i had
symptoms since like april
and it was since i came back from
l.a when i came back from being in l.a
um
and i think the first symptom was just
lower back pain had a lot of lower back
pain i thought at first it was sitting
at computer all day yeah you know we
both said computers just having a bad
back not sitting properly yep that's
what i thought he was at first
yeah just positions the other just our
position not slouching
um but it just didn't get better and it
was a very weird sort of eight campaign
went to my doctors and stuff went to a e
and stuff and they thought it was like
kidney stones or whatever they didn't
find anything and then it went we went
for a little while
and then um july i woke up one morning
and i just found it very difficult to
breathe and i was like what's going on
here i thought hey you know why am i out
of breath it's like it's like you know
when you go for a very intense sprint
yeah run a sprint up and then you
suddenly stop and you have to like bend
over like take your breath yeah that's
what it was like on a monday morning
bloody hell that's been scary yeah it
was it was very scary because
i was just like i was just like well i
can't speak yeah um
sudden ambulance came a little drama an
ambulance came picked me up took me to
the hospital they did a bunch of testing
stuff
and the first thing they found was that
i had two blood clots two uh pulmonary
embolisms one in each lung
um
i was just like what um and they asked
me had i traveled recently and i go yes
i had been to la
um so they think
well part of the reason why i had the
blood clots was because i was on a
12-hour flight and i didn't get up once
in that fight i didn't even go to the
toilet so
blood pulls in your feet it doesn't go
up through your body but over time that
those blood clots have obviously come up
and
been introduced into my lungs but
what was also another
factor in having those blood clots was
the lumps in my lungs that i had from
the cancer so i had 12 lumps in my lungs
12 12 lumps in my lungs they were the
biggest was around 18 millimeters in my
lungs
yeah they were sort of just all spread
around my lungs and stuff um and
obviously that was making it difficult
for the blood to go through my lungs
yeah
so i asked my doctor well my oncologist
how how long do you think i've had the
cancer for and he goes
we think you might have had it for
around 12 months and i was like what
whoa
i was like because i i had no other
symptoms yeah um
you know i
because usually i think with testicular
cancer everyone expects like you're down
there to become enlarged
it wasn't like that for me i had a
different type
and yeah so like july 7th i was
diagnosed
um i was in the hospital for like two
days three days okay and then i started
chemo
on the last week of july yeah last week
until i say within three weeks
i was on chemo i was doing chemotherapy
what did that feel like when you
because you're you're like young you're
like you would have been like 27 at the
time and i'm imagining like if we had a
27 year old on the ward who's come in
with shortness of breath and we're like
oh they've got two pulmonary embolisms
oh and also they've got 18
sort of
18 metastases are from a testicular
cancer primary uh
like in in their lungs it's just
absolutely mind-blowing as the doctor on
the other end like what what was it like
for you as as the patient i think that
was the shock the other doctors had like
just like
you know doctors seeing all that were
like what the hell how did that happen
um
honestly at the time i was just like
what i i was just like is this really
happening to me because um
i was fit and healthy before i got my
cancer i was actually probably in the
best shape i've ever i had ever been
better shape than when i was a teenager
going to the gym four or five times a
week i was eating properly you know i
was quite slim
i wasn't absolutely shredded or ripped
but i was just in very good shape and
that's what shocked me even more because
i was like you know
how how do you even get this yeah so
like
the first thing i did was i researched
an absolute ton i spoke to doctors i
suppose i looked online i looked at all
these different things
and getting testicular cancer is
literally just
almost like a random generator yeah like
it is completely random there's no
there's no things that cause it
the only thing i think people say that
cause it is maybe if you've had it
previously in family but none of my
family have ever had it
no one in my family has ever had that
type of cancer
so
yeah like for me i was just like
okay
i don't even know what to do i don't
even know what's what's next i i did
very much sort of take
i took the week sort of just week by
week because i knew okay i've got to do
this week of chemo i've got to do this
this i'm going to do that yeah um and i
kind of just thought to myself
especially looking at all the studies of
testicular cancer seeing that
is it crazy to say it's the best cancer
to happen yeah
it's often described particularly yeah
yeah because it's the most curable yeah
i think it's the only cancer that's
curable as well there are no other types
of cancer that are um
so i was obviously quite positive about
it in that way too at the same time i
was like hysterical crying and whatever
you know because who wouldn't if you if
you get told you have cancer like what
yeah how can this happen to me
so
yeah i'll just take giving week by week
pretty much okay
yeah that's just like
yeah i can't even even begin to imagine
what what that was like for you
i messaged you you did yeah i messaged
you and i'll because
i can't remember why i messaged you or
what
yeah i i can't remember why i messaged
you or what i messaged you about
because i'll say i was very emotional at
the time yeah i remember i think i was
telling you i was just really angry yeah
yeah yeah we talked about this at the
time
because like i was just like how did it
not get caught earlier i think that was
my biggest issue like because i said i
went to
a e or i went to hospital in april with
a lower back pain how did they not catch
it then
um
[Music]
but yeah it's just crazy i think about
it now so what was the experience of
starting chemo like
oh chemo is the worst thing i can eat
it's the worst thing to describe
i feel like
i don't really know how to explain it's
like being a zombie okay
it is like being a zombie it's like
it's like
you you have this body and you have this
brain that you can't control but you
still you can still understand what's
going on
but you can't control anything like i
could i couldn't even look at a tv i
couldn't look at my phone i couldn't
look i couldn't focus i couldn't drive i
couldn't do anything when i was on
keyboard
it was just nice it is literally just
walking like you're half dead that's
that's the only way i can explain it
people obviously say chemo as hell but
honestly like it's it's
it's worse than like you can even think
it it's like it's it's okay it's awful
so it's fair to say you won't want to do
it again no no okay
not unless obviously i have to yeah so
how long were you in zombie mode for so
i had i had 10 weeks of chemo
um and it was in three cycles
four yeah three three and a half cycles
sort of so
i'm going for the first week and i'm
going for three days eight hours a day
oh so i would be sitting there with a
drip in me um iv or whatever i don't
know what their technical term is all my
all of my arms are just ruined from all
of it but i'd have the machine just
pumping the fluid through me eight
houses eight hours of the day the second
and the third week i would just go in
once um once a week for around
two or three hours
um and then i'll repeat the cycle again
you know eight hours a day for three
days for the for the next cycle and then
two weeks
what were the conversations with the
other patients like so i was by far the
youngest patient there yeah i was by far
everyone there was much older than i was
but
honestly the people who took care of me
they were amazing because
i don't know how they do it day in day
out but they're the happiest people ever
they they literally keep you happy they
literally keep you keep you positive and
all the people there as well like the
because everything everyone's a lot
older than me
60s 70s 80s sort of people
and everyone's it's almost like a big
family because everyone's going through
the same thing everyone
obviously everyone's got different types
of cancer but i was going through the
same thing i'm just sitting in the chair
yep having chemo
and it's interesting hearing their
stories
because obviously they have a lot more
life experience than i do yeah so
there's so many interesting stuff i feel
like old people always have the best
ideas right
yeah i guess it's it's unusual to spend
eight hours sitting next to a random old
person and like talking about their
lives this is the other thing because my
council was spread so so far and was so
bad
i was only i was one of the only people
there that would actually stay eight
hours some of the other people would
come and go okay so most of the time i
actually wouldn't have the same person
sat next to me okay so maybe halfway
through the day there'll be someone else
who comes to his next okay who's coming
in for their treatment so i met so many
different people it was it was great
i said it was great obviously yeah but
it was great speaking to all these
people and just socializing with them so
what are the like
what is the social etiquette around
someone sits next to you in the chemo
chair
is it like a bus where you or a bit on
the underground where you're not gonna
make eye contact is it like an airplane
like what how what does it look like
everyone says hello everybody's like hey
how's it going and everyone the first
question they ask each other
is um
what are you here for okay what's your
cancer yeah what's your key chemo like
you know what's your treatment like okay
and then
obviously the most common question i got
was how old are you yeah because i was
just i just looked like a young person
so you would say 27 between i was 27 how
would people respond to that
people just feel sorry yeah i've just
feel sorry for me they're like oh you
pull thing yeah or you don't deserve
this yeah
obviously it's like it's really nice
because all these old people like they
treat you as if like they're your son
you're their son even um you know they
treat you as if you know that they they
need to take care of you in a way yeah
which is nice because like you know it's
nice having all this support from all
these just strangers people who just we
just want to see you get through it yeah
which is great
because because you don't
you sort of strike me as similar to me
in that i feel like you're not
big on
sharing your emotions and getting
emotional support from other people
generally correct me oh you are okay so
i guess there's should i say online yeah
i guess
that's not really the the persona that
you no i i can understand that
especially on my youtube channel yeah i
think i feel like you
you you put across a very like put
together like
i think it'd be quite interesting seeing
when people watch this yeah because i
feel like there's a lot more casual yeah
you're more smiley here than i've ever
seen you on your youtube channel yeah i
know and we're talking and we're talking
about you having cancer
so
yeah i think
i think
i definitely haven't i am an emotional
person
but i was really lucky to have people
friends around me at the time for
emotional support and like supporting me
and stuff making sure i was okay i had
friends with like trying to visit me
obviously at the time i had to be very
careful because clover was going around
yeah and when you have chemo your white
blood cells just disappear right
so i couldn't see anyone really but
people would call me people facebook
time me message me they would always ask
how i was there and i remember before i
actually started the chemo i literally
had all of my friends and family all
come and visit me in like three weeks
like people hadn't seen for years have
come and seen me and it was just nice it
was nice having that support
and it was nice like just knowing that i
can call any of these people and be like
i need this and they would be there for
me it was very sick
what sort of life lessons do you learn
from the old people that you were
chatting to in that time if any
i feel like old people love importing
wisdom on younger people so i imagine
you would have you would have got a lot
of that well i think i was lucky in a
way with most of the people that i spoke
to um
they were just very much just like
happy-go-lucky okay just like
do whatever the hell you want because
that literally like everyone says life
is just too short like you know if
everything is too serious everything is
too too like
if you take everything too seriously
nothing is fun and like you know just
enjoy as much as you can and i think i i
was like that anyway luckily i think i
i'm already in that sort of mindset of
hey you know
i'm in a very fortunate position where i
get to do stuff that i enjoy already for
work i just happen to also make money
with it that's the great thing and you
know i live comfortably and stuff and i
enjoy myself i see friends and family i
socialize like look i'm here with you
socializing you know i enjoy this sort
of stuff i enjoy i enjoy socializing
with people hanging out with other
people
and i thought that's what a lot of these
older people taught me having
experiences with other people and just
taking things as they go pretty much
okay and i think that's also
why with the cancer i'm just like hey
i've done it now it's done like i've
completed it was just another another
section of my life yep i never saw it as
like oh my god like you know i do
sometimes think see myself think to
myself oh my god i can't believe i did
that well i think hmm
that was a good experience
i don't want to do it again but yeah
exactly
how do you think about the balance
between
live every day as if it's your last
versus kind of the more think about the
long term i think i think it's good to
have a mix of both
i think a lot of people think oh you
need to have one or the other no no no i
think it's important to have a mix of
both because
you don't want to for example i know
people say oh you know when you're young
you should you should enjoy yourself
spend all your money you know get drunk
eat whatever you want but
you know what if when you're 50 60 years
old and you start having health issues
but if you don't have enough money for
retirement you've got to think about
both you've got to have a good balance
of of the two i think and
i've found from you know things like
being in just going to the gym i
wouldn't say you know i'm like properly
in shape but i try to i try to be
and i try to eat healthy and like we
were talking this morning i don't drink
coffee really um
because
i i want to just be able to
be 50 60 years old and be like oh you
know
i'm still i'm still fine i'm still going
through life completely fine i'm still
fit as a fiddle i'm still doing whatever
i want to do and i don't have any other
sort of health issues so you don't drink
either no i don't drink alcohol yeah and
like i guess like
when
when a lot of young people hear that
someone is tea turtle they think oh oh
well
aren't you sacrificing enjoyment of life
yeah
the amount of
times where i've been to a restaurant or
a bar and i said i don't drink and the
looks i've gotten people like oh you
must be well boring or you must not have
had fun i'm thinking like
it actually says a lot about you because
it means you have to get a bit drunk or
a bit tipsy to have fun why don't you
have fun as you are
like that's how i see it because i think
i think if you can't find a happiness in
just like
not having any sort of drugs in you then
you know there's another underlying
issue there
nice
so uh
other than i mean i was obviously going
going through the experience and it
sounds like the cancer has taught you to
to double down on this thing of
enjoy every day on its own merit but
also think about kind of long-term stuff
have you had any other kind of lessons
that you've that you've learned from it
that you would kind of share with other
people i think the biggest the biggest
thing i definitely know from cancer is
not giving
well giving less of a [ __ ] then caring a
lot less about what other people think
of what other people say that's why i
shared the video of me sharing that i
have cancer because i thought to myself
there are going to be some people who
comment this that and the other saying
that hey you know you deserve to have it
or some trolling or whatever yeah but i
know there's always going to be some
people who are going to benefit from it
and
you know there have been people other
people who have reached out to me
where they're like hey i'm so glad you
shared your cancer story because if it
wasn't for you i wouldn't have
discovered that i also have cancer that
i've i wouldn't have known the symptoms
i wouldn't have known
what what it's like
so
i've realized i just need to
yeah like i realized i i need to stop
caring a lot less about what other
people think and just do whatever i
think is best
but i feel like you need to have a good
balance there because obviously you
don't want to come across as an [ __ ]
either of course yeah you know you don't
want to be going around thinking you're
you're all that basically you want to
you want to be able to have a good
balance okay
so just in terms of like a a public
health announcement what what are the
things that you would encourage people
to be looking for with regards to
testicular cancer slash any others
i'm not sure i'm the right person
because and you've been through it like
i've got a bullet point list from med
school that i barely remember but yeah
but the thing with with cancer and with
cancer in general obviously it affects
everyone differently so the symptoms you
might have are different
um i feel like i don't really want to
say the symptoms on camera because
because mainly because
something someone could have that
symptom but they actually might not have
cancer so i would just recommend for
example going on a actual cancer
research website or the nhs website and
seeing the actual information on there
because that's where i found the
information
that i needed and that's how i realized
because i remember the day when i went
to hospital
and i remember sitting on a bed and then
telling me i had cancer
i feel like i knew before then that i
had it all of the symptoms all the
things i i had already read about and i
had met basically the criteria it was
just a matter of having an actual
doctor telling me that hey you've got it
i think it is literally just a matter of
taking care of yourself and and just
looking at proper official
medical websites for life
symptoms rather than some random job
blogger yeah
you know how how
how often do you do self-examination and
stuff these days
self-examination yeah
well clearly not often enough i do i do
it maybe once every few months when i'm
in the shower and i remember i it's
often when i just sort of i just i just
think of you and then i think i should
do something exactly guys ali's just
mentioned to me that he thinks of me
when he
some of the time maybe maybe once every
few months i don't know whether i should
be
impressed or disgusted
i mean it's weird because like actually
i should i guess i shouldn't be proud of
that because it means that i've had that
impact on you right yeah i've had the
impact on your way like hey my you know
olly my friend has had cancer maybe i
should just check yeah you know
which i think yeah
maybe whoever's watching this check
yourself make sure you think of me as
weird as that sounds
so i've got a few things i wanted to ask
you specifically about so you
you say quite a lot in your youtube
videos
uh words to the effect of damn i'm a
lucky dude i'm so grateful for the life
i'm living
um i am honestly very very grateful to
be in the position yeah
how how much would you feel a luck has
played a role in your success so
this is a weird thing good luck because
it's not a thing that you can measure no
but i like the idea and the phrase that
a lot of people say where you make your
own look you put yourself in positions
you you you sort of
um try try to make all these different
things align to work together and i
think
i think that's where
maybe i've gotten a bit lucky for
example i feel like i'm being i'm lucky
here to be on the podcast with you to be
on this video with you because
inevitably obviously you have a lot more
subscribers i do have 2 million
subscribers i have like 200 000 i have
the 10th that you do but
you know
here i am because we get along because
we're good friends here i am and
hopefully some of the people who are
going to be watching this are going to
also come over to my channel yeah
everyone subscribe to ollie a link below
definitely subscribe
otherwise
um
i think those sorts of things are a mix
of luck and a mix of just being in the
right position right place
but that's also not really luck though
that's like
sort of you see yeah everyone has their
own interpretation right yeah i guess
the way that i that i think of it it's
it's that luck is sort of two things
number one is like
how often do lucky events happen to you
and then secondly what is your ability
to capitalize on those lucky events sure
and so
i think of for the first one how often
do lucky events happen to you
by sticking yourself on the internet you
just
5000x is the amount of lucky things that
can happen to you just because more
people know of you and more people are
exposed to you and i've been following
your videos for a long time and so when
when we first i i don't know i think it
was like instagram dm or something well
no
this is the funny thing i think you
followed me before i even knew who you
were yeah i've been following you for
ages you just go to the vibe and then
the apartment setups and stuff i think
my friends watch more of your videos
than they do of mine because they're
like oh my god
oh you know have you got that tv you
know the lg sponsorship that ollie
you're gone you should definitely get
one of those absolutely
yeah so
the first time i came across you
was you actually left a comment on one
of my videos oh you left a comment on
one of my videos and then i went to your
channel yeah and i just thought hey
who's this sally guy i didn't really
know who you were and then i think you
left another comment on one of my videos
and i was like oh this this guy seems
like a nice guy like he's a youtuber
from the uk
and then
i can't remember how he actually i don't
know how he first connected it must be
an instagram dm no no it wasn't because
now cause you don't follow me
yeah
i think it was twitter oh it twittered
me yeah
yes
i think it was yeah
but i can't remember our first
conversation i'll be honest i feel like
it might have been around the counter
time really possibly i don't know
because i had a call we had a call yeah
we did have a call and that was before
was that before the cancer stuff that
was before because obviously i would
have been like hey you know oh i can't
remember let's have a look i think it
was very very close to the cancer stuff
going through old messages yeah we have
quite a lot of twitter dms oh
it was
when you got the tesla
and i messaged you saying in november
2019 saying did you get this as a
business expense i've been trying to
research that side of things but
couldn't find much in the way of
information
and then we kind of got talking about
your your tesla
and then six months later in may you
messaged me being like enjoyed your
video surprised how much you earn
surprised you haven't got yourself a
tesla yet
and then we talked about skillshare and
about like sponsorships and stuff nice
so funny
yeah but so i think so kind of going
back to this luck thing it was like
you just expose yourself in a non-weird
way to look by putting stuff on the
internet and then you capitalize on
lucky lucky breaks by just being a
generally nice person and being kind of
taking initiative and stuff
um at least that's kind of how i how i
think about it yeah the thing with luck
is as well is i hate it when
people say for example like you or you
or me
we've built our our youtube channels
we've we've built our online businesses
from nothing like we've not had anyone
help us do those okay you haven't had
any money injection have you no but i
had a huge unfair advantage of the whole
like cambridge thing medicine thing like
i i was really leaning heavily on those
at the start because how many doctors
still just do uh yeah
how many doctors are still doing
whatever they do um you still took that
that step
of putting yourself online or start of
teaching other people of starting your
med um remember coming backs after what
it's called but you had like a teacher
studios and stuff yeah you did all that
sort of stuff
a lot of people aren't going to bother
to do that sort of stuff
and i feel like a lot some people will
say oh you you're lucky to have this you
like to have that no no no no like
all of that sort of stuff came because
you took that first step yeah yeah i
guess so because i'm sure you get a lot
of messages because i get these sort of
messages hey how do i start my youtube
channel hey how do i start my business
hey you know and instead of well
you didn't ask anyone when you started
what did you do
hey what do you think should i start a
youtube channel yeah i did it because i
just wanted to
yeah i think that's
that's what that's one of the keys that
i hear from from almost anyone whereby
there are so few people who kind of do
something and it becomes successful with
a kind of
logical strategic i want to make money i
want to
achieve this thing in the future
therefore i will do it steps abc most
people that i've spoken to who are kind
of traditionally successful it's been
much more about let me do this thing
because it seems cool and fun and
interesting right now and
at the same time it also seems a little
bit sensible because like doing heroin
is like fun but you know from what i've
heard but it's also kind of like
um we will keep that keep that one on
the dl um but you know stuff like
starting youtube channel or starting a
business there is an element of you know
this this would be a sensible thing to
at least try there's also a big element
of this seems kind of cool it seems kind
of fun and the people who can enjoy the
journey are the ones who end up kind of
reaching the destination but i find that
often you realize that actually it's not
really about the destination it was
actually more about the journey all
along and yeah i agree because you i've
always seen you say that online it's not
about getting to a destination because
because once you're there you're always
like oh whatever yeah
very much is about the journey and i
agree i agree with that statement
because
i think to myself hey you know i'm doing
all this sort of stuff but what's the
actual end goal here i don't actually
know i don't know what the end goal is i
feel like what ends up happening is like
you get a nice thing you get a customize
to that nice thing you're like okay i
want the next nicer thing
which is a very
bad trap to fall into yeah and i think a
lot of people do that and you have to
sometimes pull yourself back and think
to yourself damn man i'm so lucky to
have the house that i have or have the
car that i have and that's why i like
you know
what i say i always like to say in my
videos i'm lucky well i'm in a fortunate
position to have all these different
things because there are so many people
who don't there's some people who who
are still you know doing who are still
living paycheck to paycheck and stuff
but i know for me for example
if i lost all of my work if i lost all
of my income and stuff i have enough
money i have enough like savings and
stuff where i could be jobless for like
two or three years and i'd be completely
fine and unfortunately not everyone is
in that same position
do you have any kind of gratitude
meditation journaling type practice for
this sort of stuff i don't have any sort
of um
like i don't write anything down
journaling i feel like is something i
should really do because journaling is
such a good way to see what you did on a
specific day instead of all the days
becoming a blur
but
there are moments like where i'll just
sit at my computer i sit in bed it can
be anywhere i'm just like man
i'll just reflect i'll just be like yeah
but i'm just so lucky i'm just so lucky
to
do the things i do yeah to really not
have many complaints
especially when i see like other people
other friends when i see you know when
you see news stories i feel like reading
news online is probably not a good way
good mental health thing but you know
even like for example with the black
lives matter thing all that sort of
stuff i think to myself man like there
are some people going through some
really hard stuff and
here i am like you know pretty easy yeah
like you know i'm just living quite
comfortably
really good time making youtube videos
and like i wish everyone could
experience the same thing i really i
really wish everyone could if someone
was in your position as a teenager who
didn't want to go to university and
they're struggling to find what to do
what would be your advice to them for
whatever that's worth
i'm sure you do yes
and it's a really really difficult
question to answer because it varies
from person to person
if i could actually go back
and do computer science at university i
would
because it's what i enjoy doing
so
finding that thing you enjoy
i think is the tough part because a lot
of people and i think they they really
know what they enjoy yep um
in our sort of day and age you could say
i sound like an old man saying that but
you know you can you can literally find
a career in playing computer games which
is just absurd when i was i'm sure when
you were a kid when i was a kid playing
computer games and making money that's
the most craziest thing ever like he
what so it's hard i think it it
is really hard question to answer
i don't have an answer if i'm honest
um but i think it really is just a
matter of finding what you love to do
and seeing how you can monetize that
thing yeah the way i kind of think of
this is that if you
if you can do that then that's fantastic
like if you genuinely find something
that you love to do and can also
monetize it then you're you're kind of
winning winning already
the thing i often think about is
what if
like for the people who a don't really
know what they love to do
slash the thing they love to do i.e i
don't know baking or playing the guitar
is a probabilistically unlikely thing to
actually be able to make money from
um like people are unlikely to become
the next john mayer or to become the
next
insert baker name here
um and so in that in that context
often like yeah do you
how how would you think about like if
you knew someone who's in that position
someone in that position i i think i
would tell them to try everything yeah
it's like dabble with a lot of stuff
yeah dabble with all sorts of like types
of jobs
um because especially when you're young
you're in a very good position i think
when you're when you're when you're 16
17 18 19 even i thought i've got up to
25 even up to 30. you can do so much you
can do so many different things
and
i feel like you're most likely going to
come across something that you're like
i could see myself doing this in 10 20
years because
i think
that's an important thing for me as well
whenever i do anything whenever i start
anything i think to myself
you know even if this didn't make a lot
of money now could i still do it in five
or ten years
and if i can then i then then i think
okay i'm gonna do this because even if
it doesn't make me money for the first
year or two
or even if it's not monetizable for
however long as long as i can keep doing
it as long as i can enjoy doing it then
let's just see how you guys say yeah
that was a really good quote from uh
when uh marquez brandley was interviewed
on the y combinator podcast uh where he
said that to be honest the secret to
success is pick something and work on it
for 10 years
and like if you genuinely if you enjoy
working on something for 10 years it is
almost
it's unfathomable that it wouldn't be
successful in some way and basically
yeah
i can't remember is it like a thousand
hours or ten thousand hours when you put
ten thousand hours into something
you're most likely like yeah pretty one
percent pretty good yeah you're probably
going to be one of the best in it which
makes a lot of sense because you know
this is like going sorry like i was
saying earlier i'm a big gamer i like
playing computer games a lot apex
legends is one of my favorite games
right now yeah i've invested 1500 hours
into playing that game
i sound pretty good you know for the
nerds out there my kb is like five my
win percentage is like 28 something
ridiculous like that um
but like
i think to myself you know if i if i
kept playing if i kept putting more
hours into that i could probably be one
of the best in the world
and
with that i could naturally maybe make a
youtube channel maybe get into esports
and stuff and that's again another great
way to make money but you just got to
make that commitment like you like
markets are saying like you're saying
if you can see yourself doing it for 10
years and you do it for 10 years you're
most likely going to be one of the best
in it if you had 20 million in the bank
and you never had to worry about money
ever again what would you do
if i had 20 million in the bank
i still play games okay still playing
video games yeah do you mean work-wise i
mean what i okay i love it be more
specific like what would your day and an
ordinary day in your life look like
that is different to what it and and to
what extent is that different from what
it is now
it's a good question because i think
when you hear a lot of people who've
made that sort of money their lives
don't really change that much in terms
of what they do because they still keep
doing what they're doing before
but
if i think of it from my position where
i am right now i think to myself i would
probably still do still be doing youtube
okay i'd probably do more photography
yep i'd probably i would probably travel
a bit more
because i could afford to go first class
everywhere
and i would spend a lot more time
with friends and family because
for example david dobrik great example
he just goes out and buys cars for
friends i would absolutely love to just
ask a friend be like hey what do you
need here's the money and instantly make
their life better just because i could
like something like that would be so
gratifying for me and i feel like
that is literally what i try to do
okay
so i mean apart from that last bit
around kind of buying fancy ass cars for
your friends and a bit about flying
first class everywhere yeah
what's stopping you from doing the rest
of it like right now i think i do do
quite quite a bit of it already like
gaming for example investing by
investing it's not investing just like
playing fifteen hundred hours yeah
over the last two years and i do it
because i can like i'm in a position
where i can i can i can spend a few
hours every day it's my way of focusing
on something else because obviously when
i'm playing this game i'm not thinking
about anything else i'm thinking about
the tactics of how to play i'm thinking
about what i need to do i like to become
tunnel vision when i do something i like
to become very sort of focused on that
thing
[Music]
so i think i am doing a mix of those um
the traveling like you said yeah i think
it's just a matter of like
i i don't enjoy traveling so if i can
make it as comfortable as possible then
i'd love to but
yep
yeah i think like sort of the um
first class is like a different level of
wealth
um and then apparently the next one is
private jet
which is like an even more like obscene
yeah
i mean yeah because i'm sure you've seen
like the craziest thing about a private
jet is you don't have to go to an
airport you just turn up on the strip
and you go on to the gym and you just go
like
what yeah wow
and you can just be like to the pilot
hey let's go here and they'll just go
like what that's just absurd to me but
what a position to be in if you ever do
get into that
[Laughter]
amazing i think that's a pretty solid
place to end this i guess uh final
question is any any final parting words
that you would like to share with anyone
listening yeah subscribe to my channel
now honestly like um
i think like like if we go back to the
cancer thing i think it is just a matter
of i think the biggest thing i've
learned is not caring about what other
people think and just just doing
whatever you want doing whatever
is healthy
but doing whatever you want
really just not caring about what other
people think
good place to leave things yeah i feel
like i i often have
this with regards to the medicine stuff
where my mum has a very strong
preference that i do medicine
and super crazy typically
and i have a strong preference of like
medicine is fun but it's just not as fun
as the stuff i'm doing right now and
given that i feel like i'm in this very
very privileged position where i can do
what i want um
you know
full-time medicine certainly wouldn't be
on that list of things
but yeah
anyway good shout out thank you for
coming on the podcast thank you for
having me everyone subscribe to alia and
um we'll see you on the next episode of
whatever we end up calling this podcast